hi I'm Erik Bosse and a ventures in game
is now available on digital HD soon
blu-ray meaning we finally have a look
at the variants deleted scenes removed
from the film removed for reasons
ranging from animal cruelty to public
urination and making it sound worse than
it was
but these deleted clips actually give us
a lot of insight into the even fuller
three hour and 10 minute movie and game
almost was now I already broke down the
taken the ultimate ending with Tony
Stark's death go check that out when he
can but here let's break down the other
5 deleted scenes for all the fun details
that you might have overlooked it for
the warning for everything MCU related
at this point here we go alright let's
start with this Thor and rocket deleted
scene from the Asgard sequence of the
time heist rocket was sneaking up to
find Thor relieving himself over a
balcony yeah so much for laying low but
then Thor says and I saw all these
people who died so this is a little bit
difficult for me I just emitted so in
the in-game theatrical cut Thor's
awkwardness and clumsiness in Asgard
seem like byproducts of his general
drunkenness but also depression over
revisiting his mother on the day of her
death and yeah his discomfort at the
idea of seeing his ex Jane Foster
especially when he looks like that but
now this deleted scene shows that it's
also a matter of walking the halls of
his old home after seeing it torched and
obliterated by searcher and Ragnarok
that's gotta be pretty traumatic and
Thor must feel a bit torn over wanting
to warn all of his old people the worked
horn to warn Thor shrugs when Rocket
asks him for directions which yeah it
kind of defeats the purpose of Thor
being selected for this leg of the time
ice we learned at one of the endgame
panels at Comic Con that the
screenwriters used a dry erase board to
map out where each infinity stone was
each year in the MCU timeline and
knowing this it's interesting that they
insisted Thor in Rococo to Asgard in
2013 for the reality stone and Brody and
nebula go to Morag in 2014 for the Power
Stone when they could have just all
joined forces to visit the collectors
vault in 2014 when both the reality
stone and Power Stone were both briefly
there the avengers combined stone trips
with the space mind and time stone in
new york in 2012 why didn't they do the
same here we've been a lot easier to do
rather than awkwardly sucking angry
reality stone sludge out of Jane Foster
they could have just simply lifted it in
canister form off of the collectors
vault shelf now I suppose we already got
to revisit the collectors of Alton
infinity war so maybe with endgame they
wanted to revisit another past MCU
location like as guard missile II the
same would have just underlined the
importance of Thor returning to his home
of Asgard since it would have been
before it exploded and Ragnarok anyway
moving on to the next deleted scene
which would have played early in the
film on Tony Stark's farm immediately
before he talked to his daughter Morgan
outside Tony and pepper make another
small talk about their alpaca Gerald
eating their goji berries
first of all Gerald is our madam
secretary lunch is in five so Tony and
peppers words here suggests that Morgan
Stark is really the one calling the
shots in this household as the only
child of a man who never received any
affection from his father also
apparently in real life Robert Downey
jr. does own alpacas okay on to the next
deleted scene this one between cap and
Rudy apparently set in the middle of the
time heist brainstorming session
Rudy asks about the events from the end
of Captain America the First Avenger
during which the tesseract fell through
the hole the Valkyrie into the ocean
below and cap crashed a plane into the
ice why did you have to crash the plane
anyway mom's on board
you couldn't have jumped out of the
plane before you crashed it so this is
just some solid trolling by roadie
asking the kind of real questions that
nerds like us bother the screenwriters
with it things like Comic Con panels
folks there just isn't always an answer
that makes sense sometimes it's just a
matter of setting up things or more
interesting story to happen it's okay
but yes they should have gone to the
collectors vault instead of that scarred
Morag also notice in the background of
the scene you can see Lebowski Thor
snoring on the sofa
Thor snore and Hawkeye and black widow
chatting probably about how deep their
pain is another deleted scene continues
this gag during the time heist
brainstorming with racket mocking the
Avengers for struggling so much against
the Chitauri in the Battle of New York
how long do you fight these guys two or
three hours hours did you tari the
suckiest army into galaxies why don't
you just blow up the mothership we
didn't know that was it
so again they're using humor to address
plot holes from past MCU films as the
rules and stakes change movie to movie
kind of like that Sheree why didn't you
just line to banner and infinity war
here Stark is the one to shame the shame
in rocket since Stark was the one to
nuke the Chitauri mothership at the last
second to save them all nearly constant
in his life and yeah resulted in the
years of psychological trauma for him
and speaking of Starks emotional state
the final deleted scene we'll look at is
from Tony's reunion with his father
Howard in 1970 there was a brief moment
between their elevator ride at the
surface and their goodbye hug beside the
car in which Tony shared with Howard the
concerns of fatherhood you start
worrying about a legacy you know you
want to leave them the better world and
then you realize you haven't done all
that much to give me one when I come
work for meat pies I'm a little tied up
in futures trading futures
I understood that reference if you think
about it Tony by talking about his
concerns to do more to leave a legacy
for his daughter Morgan is also trying
to Howard be a better father to his
younger self
he knew long after Howard's death that
all of Howard's creations are really
about leaving something behind for a son
Tony but Howard never openly conveyed
that to Tony with any affection now
Tony's trying to impart onto the Howard
the lesson that he started discover in
the first Ironman that you can't build a
better world by being a weapons
manufacturer you gotta apply technology
to more peaceful ends now again you can
check out my breakdown of the sixth
deleted scene the alternate stark death
funeral montage in a separate episode
but of these other scenes which deleted
scene do you wish was kept in Avengers
end game all of them yeah sure
comment down below with your thoughts a
follow me on instagram and twitter ITA
vas subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns and theories of everything
marvel thank you for joining me and if
Marvel really loved us 3,000 they would
release three whole new hours of deleted
scenes string them all together to an
alternate cut of Avengers endgame we'll
wait
[Music]